this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link in the
description below go through that link
and not only do you support this show be
get a free tank aircraft or ship and
three days of premium time as a bonus
and let's get into it
[Music]
it was the shot heard around the world
on June the 28th to 1914 on a sweltering
Street in Sarajevo a gunman fired into
an open-topped car killing Archduke
Franz Ferdinand the murder of the heir
to the austro-hungarian Empire was the
push that set the dominoes of Europe
falling one by one the great nations
declared war until countries as far away
as India Japan and America had all been
sucked into the quagmire known as world
war one that quagmire would kill 20
million people and changed the course of
history but who was Franz Ferdinand who
was this obscure Archduke whose death
set the world ablaze born into a branch
of the Austrian royal family Franz
Ferdinand seemed destined for a life of
rich obscurity until one day tragic
events conspired to make him the heir of
his family's empire as Emperor in
Waiting Ferdinand implemented reforms
and worked on plans that could have
changed everything only for an
assassin's bullet to cut him down too
soon in today's bhaiyya graphics we're
investigating the life of the man whose
death started World War one and
considering what might have happened if
he had lived
at the moment Franz Ferdinand's first
opened his eyes on the 18th of December
1863 not even the greatest seer could
have predicted the tortured route that
would lead him to dying on an anonymous
Sarajevo Street half a century later at
the time Sarajevo was in the orbit of
the decaying Ottoman Empire Franz
Ferdinand's meanwhile had been born into
the chilly air of the Ottomans ancient
enemy Austria not that being enemies
meant the empires were at war in fact
they were in a period of relative peace
that had allowed Ferdinand's ostensibly
military family to become lazy and
boring
Ferdinand's father Archduke Karl Ludwig
was as staid and as conservative as a
church bell tower his mother Maria and
as yatta was a bourbon princess who'd
done nothing of note yet for all their
dull respectability the family did have
one claim to being interesting Carl
Ludwig was the brother of Franz Josef
the Habsburg Emperor of Austria not the
Franz Ferdinand's got much out of his
famous uncle though
since Franz Josef already had a son
Rudolf there was little chance that
young Ferdinand would ever become
Emperor himself obviously though it
wasn't impossible he was third in line
but it was unlikely enough that
Ferdinand was kept away from the
corridors of power even as he had to go
through the standard Habsburg upbringing
of God army and duty perhaps the only
way the boy diverged from the stand of
Habsburg mould was in his passion for
botany barla the Habsburg men valued
their guns and uniforms Franz
Ferdinand's found an unlikely outlet in
flowers from early childhood it said
that he never looked quite as content as
when he was gently pressing a rose
between the pages of a book still it's
not like Ferdinand's horticultural side
was a sign of an artistic spirit he
really did value guns and uniforms and
enjoyed his conservative upbringing the
same cannot be said for Rudolf the only
son of Emperor Franz Josef Crown Prince
Rudolf had been born on August the 21st
1858 ending a run of unwanted baby girls
but Franz Josef the arrival of a viable
heir had been such a cause for
celebration that it made Rudolf
commander of an entire infantry
regiments the
next day no word on how the previous
cavada felt about being replaced by a
literal newborn baby but while his
cousin Franz Ferdinand's would enjoy his
military upbringing Rudolf absolutely
hated it from the get-go from a young
age Rudolf had been pushed off on to a
sadistic tutor named major-general count
Leopold ghandruk or gundrick or was that
bit of a dick physical education teacher
that he had as a kid
pumped up on the 19th century notions of
manliness and given carte blanche to do
whatever he liked with Rudolf the crown
prince was made to exercise outdoors for
hours in the depths of the Austrian
Windsor guns were fired near his head in
the middle of the night to wake him up
by 1865 Rudolf was a mental wreck but
still Franz Josef refused to fog Andra
Korbel eaving Rudolf was a weakling who
needed toughening up finally Empress CC
intervenes threatening to leave their
all household if gone Recor kept abusing
their son by then though the damage had
already been done
always a sensitive boy Rudolf would
never recover from the hard years he
spent in the hands of count it were
these mental scars that would soon
entwine his fate with that a Franz
Ferdinand's
[Music]
by the early 1880s the two cousins had
grown into very different people often
as families the stage Franz Ferdinand
had become exactly the sort of man the
newly recognized austro-hungarian Empire
was designed to churn out it joins the
army and become a captain within a year
now he was in his early 20s and climbing
the ranks ready to serve his country
even his love of flowers had been offset
by a newfound passion for the masculine
sport of hunting and no one hunted quite
like Franz Ferdinand's if it moved and
it wasn't wearing an Austrian army
uniform then Ferdinand was more than
happy to shoot it it is estimated he
shot over a quarter of a million animals
in his lifetime but despite the outward
success of Ferdinand's military
upbringing it hadn't sanded off all of
the rough edges
at all Franz Ferdinand was a man with a
volcanic temper like many rich people he
was used to getting what he wanted but
whereas most rich people sulk in private
when they don't
Ferdinand sulks openly for days on end
it got so bad that his army buddies
would avoid him like we would avoid a
pedophile made of Ebola still at least
Franz Ferdinand was broadly content the
same cannot be said for Rudolf in the
years since count gone Recor had been
kicked on his sadistic backside
Ferdinand's cousin had gone from bad to
worse had become melancholic alcoholic
other colleagues that medical science
hasn't yet even dreamed of yet even as
he emotionally decayed Rudolf
intellectually sharpened at the time of
our story the Austrian garyun Empire was
home to a kaleidoscope of ethnicities
there were checks Slovaks poles
Italians Croats avene Serbs Romanians
Ukrainians
a whole lot however only Austrians and
Hungarians were represented at the top
while that had been common in empires of
the past it wasn't so viable in a Europe
now brimming with nationalism as future
Emperor Rudolf was desperate to reform
things unfortunately his father's motto
was essentially do nothing and hope for
the best Franz Josef was slow
conservative as suspicious of demands
for autonomy as he was of his heirs
reforming zeal but rather than talk
about it Franz Josef simply snide lined
Rudolf marrying him off to Princess
Stephanie of Belgium a woman so dull
she could have been used
as anaesthetic frustrated at court stuck
with a wife he hated and still dealing
with the scars of his abusive childhood
Rudolph began to drift into a poisonous
depression interestingly it was around
this time that Franz Ferdinand's life
also took a grim turn in the mid 1880s
the third in line to the throne was
diagnosed with tuberculosis a lung
disease that killed many in the 19th
century but things were far worse for
Rudolph while Franz Ferdinand's disease
was something that could be understood
Rudolph's disease was something that hit
away from sight something his family
didn't even try to understand it was an
attitude that would lead to tragedy on
January the 30th 1889 Rudolph now
extremely depressed took a 17 year old
lover baroness mary that sarah to his
hunting lodge maling there the two
signed a suicide pact
then rudolph shot her through the head
before turning the pistol on himself the
bullet that passed through Rudolph's
brain did more than just kill the crown
prince it ended Franz Josef's line
extinguishing his only male heir it was
a moment when history trembled then
pivoted on its axis when the multi-verse
branched poor franz ferdinand didn't
know it yet but Rudolph's two gunshots
had just set him on a path to his own
equally violent destiny
of all the unintended consequences of
Rudolph's suicide Franz Ferdinand
becoming heir was likely the most
unintended of all that's because
Ferdinand was third in line to the
throne after Rudolf decided to decorate
mailings walls with the insides of his
skull
the succession passed to Ferdinand's dad
pal Ludwig but Karl wasn't interested
within days had abdicated his claim and
just like that franz ferdinand
hot-headed military flower loving franz
ferdinand was the future emperor for
emperor franz josef this was a little
like being forced to swallow a pint of
freshly squeezed disappointment
Franz as Ferdinand and Joseph did not
get on the Emperor was a reserved man
who never showed emotion to anyone but
his beloved wife Sisi while Franz
Ferdinand's
well let's just say that the sulking
ends the volcanic temper had not
improved with age
even though Carl Ludwig abdicated his
claim franz josef refused to name
ferdinand as his heir he claimed
Ferdinand's tuberculosis made him unfit
to be Emperor that he might die at any
moment
so in 1892 franz ferdinand set off for
warmer climes desperate to relieve his
infected lungs the next two years the
Archduke travelled the world seeing the
sights taking in the air and of course
shooting everything in sight Ferdinand
shot kangaroos in Australia tigers in
India rare birds in Japan when he
returned in 1894 he actually brought two
stuffed elephants that had shot back
with him Franz Joseph's response he
declared his nephews hobby was mass
murder
but while the trip may have been bad for
exotic wildlife it had been good for
Franz Ferdinand's lungs the air returns
revitalized better than had been in
years belly had he reached the Empire
than he was attending balls in Prague it
was here that the stuffy Archduke met
countess Sophie chotek in the entire
history of Franz Ferdinand's life there
was almost nobody who remembered him
fondly he was too quick to anger too
prone to socking too much of an [ __ ]
the one exception was Sophie chotek
somehow this bohemian countess brought
out a side in this gruff unlikable man
that no one else ever saw a side that
was tender but was respectful maybe
Sophie was the closest human equivalent
Ferdinand ever found to one of his
flowers something rare and radiant that
made him feel things that
the otherwise never experienced and
naturally franz-josef hated her
Sophie may have been rich but she was in
the account us for these snobbish
Hapsburgs she just wasn't Pasha enough
so the Emperor forbid their union pushed
his new heir away just as it once pushed
Rudolf away
unlike Rudolf though Franz Ferdinand was
willing to fight all through that
miserable decades the heir argued with
the Emperor he argued with him as Carl
Ludwig succumbed to typhoid fever as
Empress Sisi was felled by an assassin
in Geneva finally in 1913 and hit the
jackpot
after years of cajoling pope leo xiii
kaiser wilhelm ii and tsar nicholas ii
all pleaded to friends joseph on
Ferdinand's behalf faced with the head
of his rebellion the head of his closest
allied nation and the heads of the
nation he desperately wanted to be
allied with all appealing to him Franz
Joseph at last relented the Emperor
allowed Ferdinand and Sophie chotek to
marry that very year but there was a
catch before he could tie the knot Franz
Ferdinand was made to sign an oath
excluding both of his children from the
line of succession and Sophie from all
official ceremonies it was a high price
to pay but it was the only offer that
Franz Ferdinand would ever get and
reluctantly he agreed it's doubtful
anyone realized it but at that moment
the multi-verse branched yet again
taking the Empire ever further from
peace and from survival Franz Joseph may
not have realized it but his obstinacy
had just doomed them all now before we
continue this video how about you doomed
some of your enemies in war Thunder
how's that for an appropriate transition
now let's just jump over to the computer
because that's a great way for me to
show you the game
I don't really walk into war Thunder in
this game this is a good-looking game
yeah we're in a tank this is a tank it's
it just looks great I have to say I was
leading up the recording software and I
did not pay attention to what our
objective was so I'm just gonna go and
find some bad guys and so let's mess
them up how great is this I bet I can
destroy this I can destroy it because
that's the kind of game this is and this
is free and if you go through our link
oh I didn't mean to knock down that tree
but it was cool that I did let's go up
here and see what's going on I bet
there's some bad guys
these guys behind me are way more
cautious which means I'm definitely
gonna get blown up but he's pretty far
away but where are we in my I don't know
it was kind of American awesome thing
okay oh wait we're not in America this
is Japan you want some of this I don't
think there was a hit somehow seemed
like a pretty direct smash thing oh come
on
ah yes I destroyed him but he hit me
somehow I am still Oscar Mike I think I
played Japan before playing a lot of
Eastern Europe for a while wash let's
just call that camouflage shall we oh
that's not good
that's not good can we bring it around
Oh turns out you can't fly a plane with
a without a wing this is war thunder get
that free tank or plane or ship use the
link below and a few days of premium
time let's go back to the video
those who fail to learn from history are
doomed to repeat it as one of those
missed quotes that has been attributed
to just about everybody but in the
context of the early 20th century
austria-hungary is absolutely something
Franz Josef should have kept in mind
having contributed to Rudolph's
breakdown by isolating in a court and
forcing him to marry someone he had
nothing in common with the Emperor was
now turning his guns on his heir the
marriage of friends Ferdinand and Sophie
chotek had been a personal insult to
franz joseph he instructed everyone at
court to ignore Ferdinand's new wife at
the same time he began pushing his
nephew away from the business of
government castrating him politically
rudolf had tried to reform the empire
but had been sidelined and now franz
ferdinand was about to suffer the same
fate so why did franz joseph so
singularly fail both of his heirs well
there's a lot of debate about this but
one possible reason is that he ascended
to the throne when he was just 18 and
simply wasn't aware that most future
emperors needed guidance and needed
teaching when Ferdinand tried to follow
in Rudolph's footsteps and modernized
the Empire he got neither of those
things the Emperor just blanked him and
this was a problem because at the dawn
of the 20th century Franz Ferdinand was
the only one with ideas for holding the
austro-hungarian Empire together like
Rudolf Ferdinand had become obsessed
with the issue of nationalism in the
multi-ethnic Empire
but while Rudolf had tried to implement
minor reforms Ferdinand's wanted to
overhaul the whole system Franz
Ferdinand's plans range from splitting
the empire into a United States of
Austria to elevating the South Slavs aka
the Slovenes Croats and Serbs to joint
ruler status alongside the Austrians and
Hungarians but don't go thinking
Ferdinand was a Rudolf Stahl liberal
absolutely not the man was a reactionary
conservative who hated Hungarians hated
Slavs wasn't that hot on Jews and
thought Austria had a god-given right to
stomp all over its minorities he was in
short a really unpleasant man but here's
the thing about unpleasant men they can
sometimes do the right thing for the
wrong reason Franz Ferdinand's plans for
liberalizing the Empire granting all men
the vote and giving each nationality
more autonomy may have come
from a cynical calculation that it was
the only way to keep his family in power
but it really would have improved things
for millions it's not beyond the realms
of possibility that a reformed federal
austria-hungary would have survived
right up to today but we'll never know
for sure because Franz Joseph nixed
every single plan that Ferdinand had in
the core to these stifled reforms turned
Franz Ferdinand into a laughingstock it
was whispered in Vienna that the air was
clinically insane that his family's
inbreeding had finally caught up with
him for a while Ferdinand tried to brave
the storm but even this insanely
unpopular man wasn't immune to public
opinion in the mid 1900s Ferdinand and
Sophie abruptly quit Vienna they retired
to their home of Cana PCEHR in what is
now the Czech Republic and settled down
to a life of domestic bliss it was
almost a happy ending
together the couple had three children
and Franz Ferdinand settled back into
his old passion of horticulture creating
one of the world's largest Rose Gardens
in another time in a place that might
have been the end of things with Sophie
a happy mother and Ferdinand quietly
pressing roses by candlelight all the
cares of the Empire forgotten but this
was Europe in the 20th century a
tinderbox less than a decade away from
exploding for Franz Ferdinand and Sophie
there would be no peace the wheels were
already in motion
their violent fate was waiting for them
[Music]
on the 28th of June 1914 Archduke Franz
Ferdinand and his wife Sophie
disembarked from a train in the Bosnian
city of Sarajevo and stepped into an
open-topped car it was a hot day and the
river running through the center of the
city was lower than usual
but as the motorcade whipped past it
wasn't the river the Archduke should
have been looking at it was the crowds
near the city's old Latin bridge near
Jellico Cabrini ovitch and Gavrilo
Princip waited anonymous faces amid the
assembled masses in the pockets of their
heavy coats sent bombs and guns near
there trembling fingertips lay cyanide
capsules then their comrades had one
goal to kill the heir of the
austro-hungarian Empire to understand
why we need to quickly wind back father
times videotape remember when we told
you Sarajevo was part of the decaying
Ottoman Empire while fifteen years after
Franz Ferdinand's birth in 1878 the
Ottoman Empire had completely decayed in
the Balkans losing nearly all of its
territories in this power vacuum the
austro-hungarians had marched taking
over Bosnia or on the strict
understanding that they were only there
to keep the region from imploding but
Vienna and Budapest had no intention of
ever leaving in 1908 that officially
annexed the region but rather than
passing virtually unnoticed it had
caused a European crisis an outraged
Russia had permanently turned its back
on austria-hungary in the Balkans Serbs
had declared the empire their mortal
enemy and now Cabrini veteran Princip
were determined to make the empire pay
interestingly though they nearly didn't
get that chance the night before Franz
Ferdinand had a premonition that all
would not be well in Sarajevo but it was
his and Sophie's wedding anniversary and
these semi unofficial trips with minimal
security we're the only ones Franz Josef
allowed Sophie to go on so here the
couple were speeding alongside the half
dry river in Sarajevo blissfully unaware
of the men waiting to kill them as the
car roared past the latin bridge kibriya
vich whipped out a bomb and hurled it
but the bomb bounced off the car and hit
a police escort behind blowing them off
instead in a panic
Cabrini ovitch forgot about his gun and
tried to commit suicide by leaping into
the river only to land on the dried-out
Bank missing the water and breaking his
legs as Gavrilo Princip watched in a
daze the car carrying his in kibriya
vicious targets just mow
away add speed it failed accepts as you
already know he had ins what comes next
was like something out of a tragic farce
the car carrying Ferdinand and Sophie
stopped at the City Hall the schedules
but rather than focus on getting the
hell away from Sarajevo everyone carried
on like nothing had happened once the
ceremony was over Franz Ferdinand even
insisted on driving back into town to
check on the wounded as someone who'd
been there that day later said we all
felt awkward because we knew that when
he went out he would certainly be killed
if no one stops the Archduke from
getting back in the car no one told the
driver to take a different routes in
case more assassins were waiting and no
one raised a finger as Ferdinand and
Sophie headed back towards the Latin
bridge where Gavrilo Princip was still
standing in shock unable to believe that
had missed his chance to assassinate the
Austrian air one could only wonder how
he felt when he saw the car motoring
back to ward him like a moving target
going around a shooting range carousel
giving him another shot at the grand
prize and it was a shot that Princip
clad Lee took the first bullet had
Sophie killing her almost instantly the
second studied in Franz Ferdinand's
chest turning his bright blue uniform a
brilliant red as the crowd set upon
Princip the cop sped away from the scene
in the back Franz Ferdinand held poor
dead Sophie chotek
whispering in her lifeless yeah Sophie
Sophie don't die stay alive for the
children as the blood seeped through
Ferdinand's tunic a bodyguard asked he
was hurt it's nothing the asset
irritable to the last it's nothing it's
nothing those were the last words franz
ferdinand ever uttered as news broke
that evening that the heir to the
Austrian throne had been assassinated
Europe plunged into a state of shock in
every capital in every embassy people
wondered what it might mean if it even
meant anything but make no mistake this
was old Europe's 911 the moments that
would change everything in just over one
months time the entire continent would
be at war
although the life of Franz Ferdinand
ended that hot dream day his story
didn't in the aftermath of the
assassination Austrian intelligence
reported the attack had been organized
by the Serbian government Vienna nearly
invaded that very same week today some
historians think this could have
prevented World War one sympathy
initially lay with Austria and a quick
strike might have been seen as justified
but the realities of the Empire meant
Budapest had to be consulted first and
both capitals wound up dithering until
the shock had faded by which point
Russia was reasserting its military
alliance with Serbia in Vienna Emperor
Franz Josef agonized over what to do it
now lost his second heir in a violent
unforeseen incident but unlike Rudolf
suicide this time there was a physical
enemy someone the Austrians could get
revenge on by July the drumbeat of war
echoing over Europe was unmistakable on
the 28th Franz Joseph officially signed
a document declaring war on Serbia
Austrian troops marched that same day
yet even now world war 1 was not
inevitable it wasn't until Russia began
to mobilize to defend Serbia that Europe
hit the point of no return the site of
Russia mobilizing scared the Germans who
in turn began mobilizing against the
Russians the wrench then got double
scared and began to mobilize against the
Germans which led to the German decision
to attack France first fire Belgium
which in turn dragged Britain into the
war it was the dominoes falling one by
one adding up to a chain reaction that
couldn't be stopped
by August Europe was at war it wouldn't
end until 20 million were dead and
austria-hungary the Ottoman Empire and
Tsarist Russia had all collapsed into
dust not the friends Joseph lived to see
it though the elderly Emperor died in
1916 halfway through the war it's
possible that's on his deathbed he
looked back on both rudolph and franz
ferdinand his two dead heirs and wonders
if their reforms might have saved his
empire the last time franz ferdinand
appeared in history as anything other
than the trigger for world war 1 was
1917 that year a huge statue of him was
unveiled in sarajevo on the very spot
where he was killed it was a heartfelt
tribute from the city's austrians it was
also a short-lived one after World War
one ended and Austria collapsed the
statue was destroyed later under Tito's
Yugoslavia it was replaced by monument
celebrating not the murder transferred
but rather is assassin Gavrilo Princip
today Franz Ferdinand has been almost
entirely forgotten sure his name is
famous his place in the history books is
assured but the Ferdinand we remember is
not a full person he's just a symbol a
single image of a portly man in silly
clothes sat in an open-topped car
seconds before his death shattered an
entire world his face and name may
remain but his soul has been forgotten
it said that some men are born to
greatness
while others have greatness thrust upon
them the life of friends Verdun ends
belongs to another much blessed known
category one of men who were not great
or even particularly notable but without
him we wouldn't have the modern world he
may have been Moody he may have been
hard to love but Franz Ferdinand's was
also a human being next time November
rolls around and you see someone wearing
a poppy spare a thought for the
accidental add for the man who in death
unwittingly changed history so I really
hope you found the video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe brand new videos just like
this several times a week and when your
subscribing hit the notification bell
also please do check out our fantastic
sponsor war thunder they are linked to
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]